[Music]
honestly if you would have told me when
I was on Austin ally you're gonna play
Jeffrey Dahmer out if I'm like no way
but anything's possible former Disney
heartthrob Ross Lynch is all grown up
and taking on a much darker role Jeffrey
Dahmer I now present to you Jeff Jeffrey
for this time Jeffrey you playing a high
school version of one of the most
infamous serial killers ever to live
essentially my friend Dahmer is based
off a graphic novel of from der factor
who was actually went to high school
with Jeffrey Dahmer right and it was
sort of his experience he didn't
actually obviously think that he was
going to become a serial killer yeah so
um it's an interesting story yet Jeff's
a little off yeah I think he's kind of
Larry's very different from what we've
seen you as was that kind of a goal in
taking on this project it was definitely
yeah yeah oh it wasn't it wasn't like
the main goal mm-hmm but it was a reason
the content matter was very interesting
to me the fact that it was a serial
killer and then obviously coming from
this just kind of puts the cherry on top
when I like bones it interesting what's
inside how familiar with were you with
Jeffrey Dahmer story because you were
born after I was died yeah I actually
had no idea who he was
really the the script was like my
introduction to Jeffrey Dahmer I've
researched Jeffrey Dahmer kinda before I
read the script so I already had that in
the back of my head and that's really
what makes this going to be so powerful
because we don't we don't see any you
know we don't see any murders we don't
see any blood it's all about what's not
being said walk me through the process
in preparing for this and mentally I did
a lot of research what was really good
is there's a lot of footage from Dahmer
after he got caught where he kind of
walks you through everything that he did
and why he did it and that's really
where I did most of my research just cuz
I like to watch him and kind of see how
he was and how he moved in certain
things like that one of the things that
surprised me most was how charismatic he
was he that's really how he got most of
his victims you'd go to these bars and
he
just bring him home I'm just like
anybody else Raza is already getting
rave reviews for the flick but the 21
year olds isn't totally opposed to
returning to his roots team beach is
there gonna be a third probably not or
there's been no talk of it like
obviously like people talk of it like
yeah but you know not amongst like the
actual people who made the movie talk of
it how's it
I personally don't think that would
happen what about an austin and Ally
reunion you know we had this joke for a
long time on a tsunami where we wanted
to do like maybe like 10 years later I
can HBO special showers like gone
completely explicit but we'll see that
honestly I would be totally down to do
that would you
oh yeah what would you really I really
love all those them how those people are
really good people
[Music]
you
[Music]